la gratuité c'est un coup de à peu près
100 millions d'euros pour la pour la
métropole
comment voulez vous qu'on puisse assumer
la gratuité et investir pour aider les
entreprises pour construire demain
donc c'est une mauvaise idée je pense
que la première question c'est
l'augmentation nous sommes inquiétés
durant le mandat écoulé de la très forte
augmentation des tarifs de sportica
nous avons déjà établi à dijon depuis de
nombreuses années donc une tarification
se libère donc bien sûr qu'il faudra
maintenir peut être amplifiée et
peut-être même notamment je pense pour
les enfants les moins de 18 ans dans les
familles vraiment grande difficulté
resterait comme on peut le faire sur la
restauration scolaire la gratuité totale
factuellement la gratuité pertinentes à
dax électrique
la gratuité sur ces navettes va vers
effectivement certainement des grands
grande difficulté économique donc vers
une baisse de ces de ses dotations de
ces deux-ci versement transport de la
part des entreprises
donc au niveau des collectivités fait
qu'ils n'ont dans un premier temps
essentiellement match n le niveau de
service par rapport à ce manque de
recettes nous d'une part et puis aussi
fait que rafa une habitude pour que les
gens reprennent et transports en commun
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que la
crise du coc vide a créé un trou
terrible dans tous les réseaux de
transport français donc on n'en est plus
à cette question d'avant la crise on a
nay comment on refait fonctionner les
transports publics aujourd'hui